hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday June 4th 2018 what's going
on how are you how you doing Lottie I'm
in Dublin Dublin Ireland I've been on a
[ __ ] plane for I don't know how long
we left LAX and what we supposed to
leave in the afternoon and then there
was some problem with the hydraulics
they backed the [ __ ] thing up they
pulled it forward to back that up they
pulled it forward like you know two and
a half hours later we finally left which
is all good because you know it's Don
Rickles says in casino rather it's you
know sped it down here then you know up
there right so I was just sitting on the
[ __ ] plane and they didn't give us
any food to get a little cup of water it
was it two and a half hour delay nothing
no food no drinks or anything and all I
was thinking I was on Air France there I
was like oh this is how these [ __ ]
people stay so skinny on there they
don't feed you nothing
so anyways but I kept my mind occupied
I was transcribing a Pantera song I get
into [ __ ] you know I [ __ ] eats up all
the time rather than sitting there a to
do that or I play solitaire on my phone
and somebody get me a deck of cards they
like you know you can just get an app
for that I'm like that is really a lot
easier isn't it plus I feel you win a
lot more with the app you know cuz it
wants you to keep playing where a deck
of cards they don't give a [ __ ] they
just want it done they got your money
that done that [ __ ] solitaire game
though don't get it don't get it because
they got like 50 [ __ ] ads every time
they shuffled the cards every time you
win a game every time you move your hand
they got like another ad they put the X
in a different spot every time if you
don't really hit the X then it goes to
another [ __ ] page you know so
somebody gets credit for a look a
viewing a click
I don't I don't pretend to understand
these things so anyways this podcast is
gonna be all over the place I'm gonna
tell you that right now
because I was debating whether or not to
do it before I left and I was like well
don't do it before you leave it'd be
more exciting if people hear you talk to
yourself in a different country that'll
add a new [ __ ] flavor they're getting
this crazy room oh [ __ ] my room service
hang on a second
Jesus Christ all right I just ate my
[ __ ] room service and I put on the
the news over here it's just like the
news back home all depressing [ __ ]
guy got caught with a gun though but
this is the difference between the US
and Ireland it was a 38 Smith & Wesson
with five rounds of ammunition when they
said what kind of gun it wasn't how much
ammunition was there I almost went oh
[Laughter]
yeah nothing but gloom and doom 31
people were hit were killed today when a
tractor went off its [ __ ] rails it has
hate heard the [ __ ] volcano erupted
down in Guatemala and she might have
heard that how it's you know great
accents and everything but just all
depressing [ __ ] a grandmother was later
a yesterday when she was found
half-eaten by her cat if we can divide
this stool
sorry I'm [ __ ] punch-drunk I [ __ ]
just ordered this [ __ ] order BLT not the
most healthiest thing there was no bacon
in it it's that rest of the world bacon
you know where it looks like ham but it
has a consistency a [ __ ] lot it was
delicious and I ordered this side salad
I specifically said side salad no I'll
[ __ ] potay eat right and they still
brought me french fries I have the side
salad but you know it is if you see
[ __ ] french fries sitting in as a
salad right the salad that's the
plain-jane girl next door
you want to [ __ ] that big titted [ __ ]
up the street right you're gonna go
after that cup of potatoes [ __ ]
mayonnaise mayonnaise over here you
can't he can't have the ketchup over
here although they brought up some Heinz
European ketchup sucks it's all natural
their yoghurt sucks it's also all
natural you know I can't even get
through a cup of it alright if I'm not
like got it you know at least four cups
of sugar and an 8 ounce thing of yogurt
like that's not yogurt to me a charity
one-year-old was fired will you do weed
it up history with five rounds of
irradiation the town will show shaken up
they took the night off to go out and go
drink
this is many Irish news anyways where
the [ __ ] am I here I'm in Dublin what I
just write Berlin is my password I
really AM dumb what do you guys listen
to this
I mean I appreciate that you listen to
it but I really questioned you sometimes
um grace thing about Ireland by the way
it's going through customs now granted I
look like a [ __ ] leprechaun you know
an older one whose kid Noah bald alright
I look like a leprechaun to Uncle okay
[Laughter]
they just let you in no work papers no
nothing guys like what are you doing
here laddie and I was like doing a show
all by yourself as I yep it's like
alright they have a good one stamp
welcome to the country you know the
other place you go to you get that
[ __ ] guy who looks like he's in the
Bourne Identity looking you up and down
and he just started thinking why you're
making me feel like I have drugs in my
ass right now you know like I'm a mule
anyways so I'm here god damnit hang on a
second
all right sorry I look congested from
the goddamn flight you know sleeping in
that recliner um never you fall asleep
on them on an airplane you always like
this is what it must be what it's like
to be in a loveless marriage you know we
just don't want to go upstairs because
your wife's in bed and you just watch TV
till you fall asleep in your phone you
just laying there in that [ __ ] lazy
boy you know or you've been married so
long that like I don't want to go up
there spares you just sleep right on the
couch doing that [ __ ] all night I
actually had a dream I couldn't [ __ ]
breathe I have that dream I don't know I
don't do well on airplanes I watched a
250 greatest goals in soccer and you
know there was some nice ones there was
some pretty pedestrian ones but I think
it was also because it's so [ __ ] hard
to score and you also said the top 250
250 like who has the [ __ ] time to I'm
glad somebody did it it took like it was
it was the perfect soccer highlight reel
for an American I got to sit there for
like 24 minutes and watch nothing but
goals you know I bet goalies hate that
[ __ ] highlight reel it's like a
[ __ ] snuff film to them you know you
know it's great I have notice about
soccer is when you score and you blast
it by the goalie high on either side
it's see they jump out of the water like
a [ __ ] swordfish it looks like you no
no no water they jump up like it like a
swordfish coming out of the water and
what's amazing is rather than just
jumping up and [ __ ] trying to block
it they always have to turn around and
watch it go in the net you know it's
like the matrix don't you think you
could jump a little higher if you
weren't so goddamn concerned you know
where the [ __ ] it's going if it got by
you you know where it is you know you
can hear the crowd you
[ __ ] right you know when it always
[ __ ] looking it's goddamn soccer
goalies there there there are no nosy
group of people I missed it where's it
going right in the back did net you know
actually I didn't even look are there
like safety nets or anything behind
has anybody ever died somebody blast the
ball misses the net and then hits some
[ __ ] kid in the face that's the only
thing that was missing from the Irish
news oh wee little daddy went down to
the pitch took a [ __ ] soccer ball to
little noggin he'll be laid to rest half
6:00 tomorrow morning I'd beef really
early [ __ ] funeral get it over with
we're all [ __ ] pasty over here the
only thing worse than burying your son
after he got hit in the face on the
pitch is getting a [ __ ] sunburn
my accent I can't do the Irish accent my
wife reminded me that guy that met me at
the airport when I was in Scotland
remember that that story I get off and
the guy had this side he had my name on
I came walking up on my head he just
goes bull I'm like what you're four five
but a little Hussein do you prefer bill
or William ball of wool them bull alone
how much Jesus Christ it's only been 10
minutes
[ __ ] oh man I should have called in sick
you know what I always mean to do when I
go to Dublin is to take a tour of the
the Guinness Factory you know I'm not a
I'm not big on going to [ __ ] on tours I
don't want to hear about Oh the Guinness
family they they [ __ ] you know they
first made their first but I don't care
just get to the part where I get my pint
you know
over here is where we put the hops and
then the hop score and the big hopper
over here and in a stair Emma well
Sheamus gets on a bicycle it's got some
paddles on it and he go he wheels around
I would keep my voice down people think
I'm really disrespecting Irish paper in
this giant [ __ ] Queen Elizabeth [ __ ]
he's sitting in a big room like the
ceiling so like this is like for Shaq or
something but I never end up [ __ ]
getting down there it's kind of stupid
though right I mean I bet I could go in
online and just see a video I know what
it tastes like kind of a degenerate
alcoholic our youth it you know is a
bunch of booze I like I'm not gonna go
there and see how they make it
salvation the whole tour getting the
[ __ ] shakes man would you like to
just dive in there
[Laughter]
a 17-year old fell into a batch of
Guinness he jovian because he was burned
from a volcano in Guatemala
he caught a jump in the ocean of
Guatemala but he was Irish so he took
the pain all the way back to London
because he didn't want to inconvenience
anybody with his own emotions I'm gonna
[ __ ] have fun over here man
this is gonna be a good time my shows
tomorrow night at the the 3 Arena you
know what that stands for it sounds like
some Illuminati [ __ ] to me was it the
three banks that are left in all of
Europe are they part of the European
Union here who decided to leave
was it Brussels no was it Brillon nope
was it Great Britain I knew it was
brexit so I just try to guess all the BR
once I spelled Berlin I pre empty our
brillant just to be interesting you know
just just to try to keep it fresh
globally
you know anyways
how about those [ __ ] Washington
Capitals I'll say it again how about
those [ __ ] Washington Capitals today
right now if I'm a fan of the Vegas
nights I got to be thinking when is my
when is our adjustment to their
adjustment going to happen alright I'm
gonna go I don't know look at this place
what happened okay the Capitals whatever
the [ __ ] Vegas was doing in Game one the
Capitals adjusted to it and Game three I
did not see an answer by the Vegas
nights okay and as far as my limited
knowledge of math goes they better
[ __ ] respond in game four or this
series gonna be [ __ ] oh no veterans
gonna be on the cup it's gonna be great
either way it's it's a it's an
incredible it's gonna be great I mean
I'm rooting for the Capitals cuz of Josh
Adam ayahs and you know and they plus
everybody down that they've been waiting
since 1974
Redskins suck the Nationals you know I
don't you know these to be the senators
the senators twice they left one time
they became the [ __ ] Texas Rangers
another time they became the Minnesota
Twins and the [ __ ] Expos came down as
the Nationals and they they still
haven't wanted title you know they're on
their third [ __ ] marriage actually
the Senators did win a title in like the
1920s I think you know they went to the
[ __ ] White House I think George
Washington was still there when it
showed up
it's [ __ ] wooden teeth and to sit
there and listen I'm boring story how he
said they made a baton
they made some teeth of his [ __ ] bats
he had as a kid how much you think that
guy lied his ass off that they had to
come up with that dumb ass story about I
could I can't I can't I can't tell a lie
I chopped down the cherry tree what kind
of ass-kicking do you think he got over
that you know when you really think
about it back then there was no
supermarkets and this guy just chopped
down a [ __ ] tree that actually had
edible fruit on it
you know most dad probably beat him with
the axe handle knocked that [ __ ]
powdered wig right off his head did rich
kids wear powdered wigs back then you
know people would come up and key their
horse [ __ ] [ __ ] you guys I've been on a
plane for 12 hours I don't give a [ __ ]
if this is funny or not I mean I do I do
care but uh anyways anyway so I watch
Game one of the NBA Finals and I have to
tell you when they [ __ ] reversed that
offensive foul call that basically every
time about JR Smith and I can't get mad
at JR Smith because I didn't know what
the score was either when he was
dribbling it out I was going yes yes it
was a lot of other people too they
thought they were up by one the game was
over on that offensive foul and you know
I've never seen them have a little
powwow in reverse
I'll call it see at me I just I had like
Tourette's when that happened and I was
so [ __ ] upset and so once again
disappointed by the NBA and the way that
they [ __ ] run their league I was so
mad I walked to my show that night I
just I didn't want to get in the [ __ ]
car I need I had to go for a [ __ ]
well I didn't watch the overtime because
I knew I knew the Warriors are gonna win
it I've watched enough games that went
up [ __ ] when they kicking the balls
with a call like that and then the Rain
Man dude on your team doesn't know that
you [ __ ] tied and he runs out the
clock you know what's gonna happen so
LeBron knew that's why I went back to
the bench he didn't talk to anybody and
I [ __ ] I had two shows in LA and I
walked to both of them I had one in a
dive bar and then another one at a
little more upscale place that wasn't
quite a comedy club and I just I just
walked to both of them and I could tell
you this right now LA has an
unbelievable homeless problem holy [ __ ]
I mean they are [ __ ] everywhere every
doorway every nook and cranny there's
somebody you know wrapped up in a quilt
like a [ __ ] cocoon a lot of mental
illness out there it's unreal it's
really unreal how we just [ __ ] leave
those people on the street you know
mentally ill people know these to have
those asylums just can't have enough
that didn't work I don't know I just
need to try to take care of him it was
really [ __ ] depressing then I was
sitting there walking down the street
going like did I really leave the safety
of my car
to [ __ ] walk amongst all these
[ __ ] people who got god knows what
kind of issues right and I was standing
in this guy with this really dirty shirt
was just staring at me and I'm waiting
for the light to say walk you know it's
LA you can't jaywalk you'll get killed
right
and then I feel him he's just staring
right at me I'm like ah [ __ ] here we go
here we go
old freckles huh couldn't take your car
could you got all mad about a basketball
game right the guy looks at me and he
goes hey and I ignore him because hey I
ignore him again and then he sort of
like walked around so he's in my vision
he goes hey I look at him I go what and
he goes are you Joel McHale I just go no
and then it said walk and I walked away
from and I felt him behind me and I just
kept walking you know and then I was
walking too fast so then there was
somebody in front of me and then he's
doing this whole kind of looking back
like why is this guy walking so quick
you know and I wanted to say to the guy
hey you don't need to worry about me
it's the guy I'm walking away from
anyways so that's what the [ __ ] I did
after game one Jesus Christ the Warriors
have to be the most hated [ __ ] team
I've ever seen in my life you don't got
enough stars on your team you got a poke
LeBron in the eye jesus [ __ ] christ
that's some [ __ ] a [ __ ] girl would do
playing nerf basketball [ __ ] disgrace
and then LeBron gets out there with his
old-ass body takes a [ __ ] charge
I know his foot was work was moving and
I know that after they looked at it you
know they did get the call right but
what the [ __ ]
think they've never reversed something
like that ever hmm it's like they were
looking for a way for the Warriors to
[ __ ] win it was just it just I don't
I don't know why I give a [ __ ] so much
why do I give a [ __ ] about either one of
these teams because what I'm rooting for
is just for sports to go back to the way
they used to be where there was still
free agency I'm not that old when I was
growing up but there wasn't these pylon
[ __ ]
Teebs you know I don't know somebody
sent me a thing about LeBron could
possibly go to the Celtics
he better not I don't want that title
you know I don't know bill you're just
old and all you do is complain I know
I'm sorry why can't I just realize that
the game isn't what it was when I was a
kid and this new game young people seem
to be enjoying and don't have a problem
with was a kid there was an old man
playing an organ um anyways let me do a
little bit advertising reads this
podcast I'm not gonna make an hour
people you know by the way this is my
last week of my 40s this is it matter I
turned 50 years old on Sunday can you
believe that I was 39 when I started
this podcast way back when way back in
2007 man when a guy named George W Bush
was president and he was the son of a
guy George Herbert Walker Bush and he he
was the vice president of a guy named
Ronald Reagan who who who used to be an
actor manufacture look at think about
everything that has happened since I've
stopped since I was 39 years old huh
robots are gonna take over the world
Miami's is gonna be under Miami's
Miami's gonna be underwater reality TV
show star became [ __ ] president we're
still fighting the same [ __ ] war
that's the one constant that's the one
thing you can hang your hat on it'd be
like oh okay
there's something I'm comfortable with
there's something I'm used to who says
you can never go home yeah how long was
it before I understood then I've talked
about that before right when they say
you never can go home [ __ ] you talking
about a book of flight right now and go
home I never understood that they meant
you're gonna go and it's not gonna be
the same people it's just gonna be
overwhelmingly
[ __ ] depressing
well anyways yeah I'm turning 50 and
actually feel good about it banged out
50 pushups the other day right that
means I'm not going to die right no my
40s were my best decade as far as my
life I got married I had a kid
Mike did a bunch of great shows got rid
of all the [ __ ] [ __ ] in my life
cleaned house cleaned [ __ ] house
anybody that was a [ __ ] bigger [ __ ]
than me you know I got rid of so
obviously it was a short list sorry easy
joke what do you what do you want from
me
huh what do you want I don't know
[ __ ] playing for last [ __ ] 12
hours so I'm looking forward to another
decade of experiences and knowledge
gaining just living my truth I feel like
for me my fifties are going to be now
I'm going to crush up my fifties I'm
gonna do yoga eat a plant-based diet
take a whole bunch of selfies
hashtag 50s hot hot 50 something stupid
like that what about the forever 21 is
for an old white guy over 50 whatever
that hash guys you guys come up with the
hashtag you don't put the hash tag and
I'll start hash tagging and I'm [ __ ]
what is it the hash tag app you guys
like hash remember hash might be your
mother used to make hash had the little
[ __ ] meat grinder why the [ __ ] Oh has
tagged that's what am i Ryan all right
let's let's let's read a little bit
advertising here authority tool year old
all right
the black tux everybody wedding season
is upon us you're gonna be doing it big
you married a fat chick and going out to
awesome all of your buddies weddings
when you're bringing a date you want to
look fresh but it has to be convenient
exactly you want to look the best you
can but you don't to be you don't to be
a pain in the ass
that's where the black tux
comes in everybody the black tux has
awesome suits and an tuxedos in all
kinds of styles and you rent them online
yeah Wrentham you go out you'll hook up
ya bang and you give it back to him the
black tux offers the kinds of suits and
tuxedos styles that would normally be
wildly expensive to buy and you might
only wear it once that's right you go to
a wedding and then you got that suit you
just waiting for someone to die now like
the Emerald shawl tuxedo it's funky it's
cool but how many times you're gonna
wear that [ __ ] an emerald green tuxedo
what do you unless you with a mascot for
[ __ ] Notre Dame you gonna wear that
they one time all right they're green
alligator that loan you look so great
last I know they said that's gonna be
sitting in there with the black tux you
can do but you can't do you oh Jesus are
they gonna tell me to keep my voice down
hang on say hello mister which I turn
down what I what it's a lot of you never
really how many are there around the
English language so you come to Ireland
cuz we you a second par por park your
[ __ ] power so try out a new look do
something different and take your style
to the next level with the black tux
free home try on you can see the fit and
feel the quality of your suit months
before your event after ordering your
suit after ordering your suit will
arrive 14 days before your event if
anything is less than perfect like if
you went out got nachos or something the
black B black tux will send you a
replacement right away and remember how
simple returns are wear it turn heads
then send it back three days after your
then shipping is free both ways stand
out at your event for the right reasons
with the black tux to get $20 off your
purchase visit the black tux comm / /
that's the black tux comm / bird for $20
off your purchase the black tux premium
rental suits and tuxedos the limit
okay simply safe you know it's important
to protect your home with the home
security system I'm considering these
[ __ ] liberals won't take away all the
guns you might as well get a safe
[ __ ] sleep in that [ __ ] how can we
protect your home and your privacy
that's what I love about simply safe
they obsess over details like no other
home security company here's an example
simply safe as a camera you can control
from your phone but they want to protect
your home and your privacy so they came
up with this brilliant idea a private
shutter for their camera now simply safe
wanted you to be able to hear the
shutter click so you know it's closed
they wanted to have a light on it so you
could easily tell when it's on and they
need it to work for the entire lifespan
of the system I don't know what I'm
talking about right now
so simply safe got to work testing
different metals and hinge designs for
months and months the result an
effective home security camera with a
thin lightweight aluminum privacy
shutter that will work every time it's
the kind of attention to detail that
sets simply safe apart and keeps your
family safe simply safe isn't just home
security it's home security done right
check out simply safe today at simply
safe bird comm that's simply safe bird
comm learn more about simply site today
simply safe bird comm by the way when
you get home security don't get cameras
in your house just get them outside
alright because you don't want that
pervert down there hacking into your
system watching you [ __ ] you laugh
alright me undies everybody or worse you
jerking off on the toilet me undies
everybody you've definitely heard me
talk about me undies you know the fun
comfy undie all but who do
biondi's me undies slapping your [ __ ]
prick to be our DS biondi's with the
[ __ ] selfie stick but you got
security looking at you now they know
you come face what are you dude you get
a 2 pairs of [ __ ] me undies 1 for
your junk and then your face you
definitely heard me talk about me undies
you know the fun comfy undies that feel
as good as they look to those of you you
haven't who haven't tried them yet
listen up you can get an incredible
underwear sent to your door with me
undies meaning no more hunting around
for the perfect pair at a crowded store
and eventually setting settling for good
enough the undies is so sure you'll love
the first penny of your not having
they'll do whatever they can to get you
the right pair and if they can't keep
them and they'll refined you oh they're
gonna walk away and be the martyr no
it's fine keep it keep it sorry I'm
sorry we couldn't please you so it's
really his risk free to try the best
underwear ever and if you're already
part of the me undies fam tell your
friends about it through their referral
program that's like Amway over thunder
where they'll get a discount and you'll
get a store credit
win-win still snot sure well me Andes
has a deal for my listeners first-time
purchasers get 20% off their first pair
of me honey's and free shipping that's a
that's 20% off plus free shipping and a
guarantee that you and your me undies
will be very happy together get your
butt over to me undies comm and treat
yourself to get your 20% off your first
pair free shipping 100% satisfaction
guarantee go to me undies dot-com / /
that's me undies dot-com / / and lastly
but not leastly
always had Lonnie stamps calm the US
Postal Service is an important tool for
any business stamps.com is the easiest
way to access all the amazing services
of the post office that's why they don't
want me to trash the post office because
they use them I get it now stamps calm
never closes print postage for lettuce
or packages at your convenience
24/7 I got the hiccups because they ate
those french fries those freedom fries
print postage for any mail class right
now from your own computer the exact
amount of postage every time never under
pave or over pay again stamps.com saves
you time and money when you can use
which you can use to grow your business
like a mail any letter in any package
using any of my computer or printer and
the mail carrier picks it up from your
lips it of to God's ears create your
stamps com account and minutes online
with no equipment to lease with no long
term commitments click print and million
you're done it's convenient it's easy
it's reliable its efficient you know
what else do you want from it I use
stamps calm to send out my [ __ ]
posters that I'm gonna be selling
tonight I'm a [ __ ] if I can figure out
how to use it so can you and right now
you too can enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale go to stamps comm and
click on the microphone stop the
homepage and type in or that's
stamps.com enter ber be you are fired
that's a [ __ ] English name that's an
English Setter name
alright 33 minutes in the Toit a tree
meditated all right should I just get to
the questions here I think I should
alright so they have a gym here why did
I eat those fries I feel like [ __ ]
[ __ ] hate when they do that Jesus
Christ
I don't know how alcoholics do it you
know when they sit there and they go
yeah you know no booze for me then they
bring a beer if they always go I you
know I don't drink I don't drink once if
they brought a [ __ ] crack pipe up
here I'd smoke it that's how that's how
weak I am I don't even smoke crack not
at least at least not during the week
alright great news flame oh yo Billy
Nova did you hear the great news you
finally have representation on the emoji
front they added orange headed people to
the emoji list nice now you can let
people you text no you really look at
the moment how you really look at the
moment you say for me I got to check
these out
let's see him go to the page yes that's
what I would like to do
none of those look like me they're all
so young add closed by Google stop
seeing this ad yes stop seeing this ad
already but not interested in this ad
we'll try not to show it again okay get
out of here beat it I hate when you
scroll down the ad goes with you like
that person that's just [ __ ] tagging
along you know you're trying to hook up
it's like get out of here oh Jesus
Christ would you look at these [ __ ]
things yeah I don't look like any of
these people well that's nice that's not
really accurate I mean they should they
should have at least one really pasty a
couple people of color in there then
they got some no nobody with blue eyes a
couple of Simpsons colored people or a
Moche colored oh well that's nice it's
nice that they're doing it I bet I mean
who at my age sends out an emoji you
know you don't emojis I use I all the
one that I use the most thumbs up thumbs
up what I love about thumbs up is it
means yes I definitely want to do that
or it means like if I can whatever we
got to get together sometime and hang
out
thumbs up not [ __ ] hanging out with
you right or I could be like [ __ ] yeah
get out doing [ __ ] drag all right I
should have made a top-10 list of what I
could do what I'm what am I going to do
here to make my 50s you know the best me
lived your truth do you realize like the
amount of [ __ ] that's going on in the
world right now okay and just how self
involved myself in literally doing a
park
just talking to myself house [ __ ]
self-involved the world is right now you
know live your truth be the best you've
50s the new 40 you know everything has
to be like um oh that's well that's
that's why you got those [ __ ]
[ __ ]
who work out in the garage and then they
start running down the street so
everybody knows they're CrossFit people
right everybody knows they're working
out it's like we get it you know I work
out too I don't go to [ __ ] start
yelling at people who haven't brunch I
don't know that you know something that
that right there remember a few years
ago they decided to do away with
bullying alright which you know is a
great thing but I think you should be
able to bully adults because the fact
that that's you know it's not it's out
of style to bully people I think is how
CrossFit actually exists you know if you
basically categorize any sort of
criticism is bullying you know how are
you gonna know when you're acting like a
complete [ __ ] tool [ __ ]
I just don't understand those CrossFit
people to be in any better shape than
anybody else doing any other workout and
they had just parading up and down the
[ __ ] Street like I don't know what
like they're inspirational I don't know
I've never like you know I don't like
people that do endzone dances I just
don't like any of that [ __ ] it's just
[ __ ] and it's just that gives me
douche chills to look at it I don't know
maybe it's a good workout I'm gonna
start doing that you know do pull-ups in
my garage and then run up and down my
driveway yelling [ __ ] so my neighbors
know that I just did a set of ten
[ __ ] pull-ups LeBron a Celtic he okay
here's a question hey there Billy Knight
quite from Boston
what if LeBron went to Boston kind of
goes without saying that winning with
LeBron wouldn't feel as good as winning
without LeBron thoughts
Jesus Christ what am I the president you
just [ __ ] give me a half-assed
[ __ ] question I got an answer I know
yeah obviously obviously I uh yeah I
would rather be LeBron than [ __ ] have
him just join my team and then everybody
but it's a [ __ ] pylon team it gives a
[ __ ] a bunch of championship yeah
obviously
thank you sir those are my thoughts I
have the obvious thought on that now I
don't want that to happen I would like
us to continue doing what we're doing we
already signed a big free agent with
what's-his-face there that hurt is me
gingivitis what the [ __ ] is his name I
don't know I'm not I'm not a Celtic I'm
gonna nah know something I'm just not a
basketball guy and I missed all the
games this year all right I got a kid
man I got a kid and I miss a lot of
stuff the guy with the beard thinks the
world is flat right is that the guy
that's the guy the guy I just wants you
know it's like the New York Yankees you
know ken kesey no they they they they
built off from their farm team and
drafting and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] and
they added one that's [ __ ] stud from
the Marlins there can't get mad at that
um I mean a couple of shrewd trades we
did give up Isaiah Thomas though I swear
to God if he still was still with the
Celtics he would have got his own he was
like he's gonna be a big papi of the
Celtics
whale of a tale bill did you hear this
did you hear about this whale by the way
has anybody seen that [ __ ] video that
poor girl calling up her ex-boyfriend
crying its
she literally sounds like the impression
me and Paul do when we do the crying
thing she'd be like hello I'm sorry I
missed your call I really hope you call
me back I love you I do want to say that
I love you and I miss you
I'm not even I'm not even exaggerating
I'm really sad that I missed your call
who [ __ ] unbelievable
alright pilot whale dies in Thailand
after being found with 17 pounds of
plastic bags in its stomach
yeah and I'm supposed to get excited
because they had [ __ ] ginger
emojis oh my god this is just what what
are we what are we doing and a male
pilot whale struggled for five days to
stay alive in Thailand near the
Malaysian border I'll tell you what's
[ __ ] crazy is those ocean currents of
everyone I think all it's from their
elation plastic bags is probably you
know from [ __ ] big fives sports in LA
Thailand near Malaysian border after
rescues found 17 pounds of plastic bags
in its stomach a you can't just eat one
they're like Doritos The Washington Post
reported on Sunday but it ultimately
succumbed to its illness the whale died
on Friday the post wrote in Toronto so
discovered that Thailand's Department of
marine and coastal resource ed were 80
plastic bags lodged in its stomach it's
far from the first time whales had
turned up sick or dead from ingesting
trash experts say that the whale likely
believed the bags were food so what are
we going to do about it what is the
solution
plastic pollution throughout the region
is exceeds anything positive here
according to another report by the
nation a 2015 study by the ocean
conservatory and McKinsey Center for
Business and Environment found that
Thailand was the world's sixth worst
offender for dumping plastics into the
sea who's number one
silence Pollution Control Department
says plastic waste is increasing by
roughly twelve percent annual with only
25 percent being reused that's pretty
good that we reused 25 percent it's
better than what we used to do the vast
majority of it is plastic bags the
Bangkok Post writes that the 23 we're
never gonna get that [ __ ] out of the
ocean by the way it's like we just
switch the cloth bags oh my god we are a
[ __ ] plague with shoes Bill Hicks
said that [ __ ] 25 years ago the
Bangkok Post writes that the 23 coastal
provinces in Thailand generate around 11
million tons of garbage daily I thought
there gonna be a year of which
approximately 1.1 million tons ends up
being dumped directly into the sea
plastic pollution throughout the region
is expected to remain a significant
issue as many Asian countries are
sparing economic growth that is
outpacing waste management
infrastructure here's the thing where
the [ __ ] do you put it you know what I
mean I don't know this is when you this
is when you need hipsters because
they're gonna go go back to
biodegradable [ __ ] just trying to be
cool but they're actually gonna create
hopefully I don't know oh boy what the
[ __ ] are we doing these [ __ ]
corporations what are they doing they're
just all about the [ __ ] money they
don't give a [ __ ]
Wars pollution they don't kill kids they
don't give a [ __ ] and none of these
[ __ ] politicians does a goddamn thing
about it
it's just [ __ ] unreal because they
need the corporation's money it's just
it's literally it's like a suicide pact
how the [ __ ] do you get out of that ah
this is the price like the Irish knows
it's the pressing all right
Massachusetts male mentality all right
here we go hey Bill I'm excited to be
going to your show your Boston show in
the fall by the way man I transcribed
that [ __ ] Metallica song and my
double bass plane is finally coming
together
I just been staking with it now of
course I'm gonna be on the road for a
couple of weeks but I'll get it back up
to speed you know Lloris has like these
four or five signature licks and once
you get those things down you can kind
of do a real shitty version of all of
their songs I still suck but like I can
actually start to be able to play along
I can definitely do like the the
sixteenth no thing but he does that
little that triplet before the snare
with the crash China that he always does
yeah that one's a little tough love your
podcast it's one of the things that
keeps me sane alright I appreciate when
you say positive things about your
relationship with your wife and now
you're so glad to be on the other side
I'm a 42 year old single female and it's
downright depressing around here I've
been married so don't need to do that
again we'd just like to meet someone who
wants a steady monogamous relationship
unfortunately the guys around here seem
to obtain their intimacy from their
relationship with their male friends
women are viewed as an afterthought at
best but usually as a nuisance or a
threat oh you're in Massachusetts I got
is easy it's an easy fix get into sports
get into sports start watching sports
increase your alcohol intake and your
guy will be your best friend you have a
head why do guys have a mob mentality
when it comes to women they seem to
think it's giving up to settle down but
don't they fear being alone later in
life
why do grown men care what their friends
think and why wouldn't they be happy
their boy is living with living a
fulfilling life I'm cute in decent shape
I'd say I'm a seven 1/2 in the looks
department
and you humble I'm being serious you
know decent shape you know you're honest
have a fun personality can support
myself and don't care about having kids
but the Schmucks I've been dealing with
lately make me feel like giving up
altogether and another mystery to solve
why do my friends and I frequently see
good looking good
why do my friends and I frequency
good-looking guys with women who look
miserable if you wouldn't mind taking a
few minutes to wax philosophical on the
benefits of relationship with the
opposite sets that would be great
a happy birthday from a fellow Gemini um
all right why did God why are guys
afraid to settle down well because women
take guys for everything they've got in
divorce court all the [ __ ] time all
right and like there's only so many of
those [ __ ] nightmares that you can
you can watch before you're like why the
[ __ ] would I want to do that I mean that
was my attitude for the longest goddamn
time and when you get into a
relationship a lot of times you are at
the mercy of the females moods and you
know there's you know there's all this
[ __ ] out here right now talking about
all this [ __ ] that guys do to women all
this horrible [ __ ] but I'm waiting for
the you know the winds to turn and pull
back a little bit and talk about you
know just this constant [ __ ] like you
know keeping you on eggshells you know
keep it happy keep it happy keep her
happy you know that happy happy wife
happy life is what they say there's no
rhyme for the dead there isn't so you
know and everything is about you guys
I'm just being honest you know the
weddings all about you Valentine's Day
is all about you the anniversary is all
about you it's all the guy what are you
gonna get her and it's like you it's all
geared that you are so [ __ ]
privileged and lucky to have this person
but there's really not that sort of
reciprocal mentality so
but when you're a single guy you know
you got the world by the balls we make
more money an hour at Dairy Queen
evidently or whatever the [ __ ] it is
that you guys are saying that happens
and you know you hang out you watch
sports you go down to the bar you talk
some [ __ ] maybe you get laid get a
[ __ ] [ __ ] you wake up the next day
not in a relationship that's really
appealing and you still have all your
money or a lot of it it's appealing
I would also you know so I don't know
I'm not I know you want me to say
something positive just answering that
first thing you guys are terrifying and
you act like you're not when you're
talking to men but amongst yourselves
you know amongst yourselves I'm sure
you're a little more honest about like
you know the sanity of you know so many
women out there is they're just [ __ ]
nuts the [ __ ] you do they'll get
pregnant on purpose I mean that they're
[ __ ] they'll bring a person into the
[ __ ] world I mean crazy [ __ ] crazy
I got to try to see something positive
here Jesus Christ why you have a problem
well you know you're also like you like
me you waited a while all those people
that are like want to find love and all
that you know you got a draft in the
earlier rounds when you were in your 20s
there was a bunch of blue-chip prospects
there now you're in you 42 you got to
try to find your six round draft Tom
Brady that's what you have to do so it's
gonna be more work but I somehow pulled
it off grant but I was 35 she was 25 I
don't know
moved up in the draft that's what I did
maybe you want to date a younger guy I
don't know but I always looked at it
this way that you know you're you know
if you're out there and you seem cool
you're out there there's gonna be your
match is gonna be out there but like
it's it's dangerous as I just trashed
women to go down that road to say
they're all like this or why do so many
people blah blah blah you start getting
[ __ ] jaded and the reality is you
could do that about anything why are
most people [ __ ] and consider it why
most people [ __ ] morons why do most
people stand in a security line at the
airport rolling their eyes looking at
you bonding it like can you believe how
long this is taking
and then they do nothing to be prepared
for when it's their time when it's show
time they just start to take the [ __ ]
belt off and all that and they become
the [ __ ] problem they don't notice it
okay that's why I'm eatin somebody
awesome it's so [ __ ] special because
there's not a lot of them out there so
you hang in there and I think you're
gonna find the person that wants to have
the relationship you want that you want
and I think the relationship you're
looking for is what a lot of guys are
probably looking for around your age
right if I was you I get a divorce see
there already had his [ __ ] kids
already did that [ __ ] and then he
can just [ __ ] you know hang with you
you're not looking to get married you
know looking to have any [ __ ] kids
you can just [ __ ] hang out and drink
Cape Carter's and watch the Pats there
you go bing-bang-boom I solved your
problem
probably not wife wants to use my
computer
oh Jesus would he got a bunch of porn on
there hey Billy Bob Burton I've been
with my girl for five years and married
for one and I refuse to let her use my
computer isn't because of porn or
cheating it's because my PC is worth
close to 20 grand what I used to work
for graphic designer animator and gaming
Hey
I didn't know they made laptops worth
that much I even had it set up so I am
not so if I'm not within three feet of
it it is locked I have a piece of
jewelry with an RF
ID chip that unlocks my PC when I'm near
it well I Got News for you do it anybody
who wants who knows anything about
computers can turn that [ __ ] thing on
from a different computer when they're
not even in the [ __ ] room I guarantee
you I told her even before we were
married that she will never use my
computer she has never had a phone that
wasn't cracked or broken the last time
she brought up my computer I bought her
$1000 PC of her own which she lost
within a week am I being too
unreasonable or am i right
not wanting to ruin my computer do you
let Nia use your computer yes I do but
like my computer's a [ __ ] mess no I
don't think you know she hasn't
demonstrated that she is can take care
of [ __ ] here's the thing if she's if she
was saying you couldn't use hers if my
wife was like you can't use my computer
this is super expensive I do graphic
design I want to use your [ __ ]
computer I hate computers have fun with
your computer you know but um you know
it probably makes her insecure because
that is where porn and cheating and all
that [ __ ] [ __ ] happens so I'm
choosing to believe you when this if
you're not doing that [ __ ] and if it
truly is because you have this awesome
[ __ ] twenty thousand dollar [ __ ]
computer then yeah I don't I don't know
what the problem is I would just sit
there you know what I would do I would
take her phone yeah I would open you my
laptop and then I have her phone right
next to it you know with the crack
screen I go look at your phone look at
my computer what's the difference Oh get
your PC to honey oh that's right you
lost it you lost it that's right so know
what what have we learned here and this
thing let her get mad she's gonna
[ __ ] storm away and be all [ __ ]
mad and then once again like I was
talking about that previous one she's
gonna you know do that whole thing where
I'm you know I'm said the Kyle Dunnigan
I'm mad at ya she's just going to do
that [ __ ]
and you know what letter you just it's
you just sit over there pout all you
want you know I'm right and then they'll
get mad they'll switch out of the pouty
thing then they get [ __ ] mad
it's a whole goddamn process just be
like no you can't you I would hold my
ground on that one just say listen over
the next year if you demonstrate that
you can actually be around computers
without breaking them or losing them you
know maybe in 12 months I'll let you
look over my shoulder yeah just tell her
that's not how life works
you have to earn things all right most
of us do anyways but you wouldn't know
that listen all these [ __ ] feminists
out there I think if you're a guy you
just [ __ ] show up people give you
[ __ ] I'm so hoping it becomes a level
playing field I can't wait I cannot wait
that's gonna be the greatest [ __ ]
thing ever when they realized what a
giant [ __ ] sandwich they still have to
eat oh it looked appetizing when you
were peeking over the fence didn't it
sweetheart all right that's it everybody
that's the podcast here
thank you to everybody over here in
Ireland even before I do the show thank
you for everybody for buying tickets to
come out to the show it's an honor and a
privilege to be here at your beautiful
Amaral aisle and I hope we give you
money's worth tomorrow night go capitals
and I you know I also like the Vegas
nights too their coach gave a speech or
something the GM the beginning of the
year an expansion franchise if you don't
watch hockey he said all you guys in
this locker room are here for the exact
same reason the last team you played for
didn't think you were worth being
protected me right there they got the
chip on their shoulder and they've been
[ __ ] moe and everybody everybody down
ever since till they ran to the
Washington Capitals I'm gonna try to
find a way to somehow watch that game
although I think tonight comes on in
like 2:00 in the morning so I might be
[ __ ] and I don't know if I can I can't
watch the [ __ ] NBA who da [ __ ]
reviews
a charging call no final - I've never
seen that before my [ __ ] oh my god
you know but thank God they did thank
God they did because I was able to I
didn't have to waste time watching the
rest of the [ __ ] game and then I you
know I you know went for a nice brisk
walk it's good for my hat
that's it guess what people were into
June which means we are only two months
away from the start of football season
preseason just like that coming around
again and the god knows the way there's
like four days off between every [ __ ]
NBA game you're probably just gonna have
to do you know the last week of June and
July and then you're gonna be right
there and you're gonna be right there
although I've gotten back into baseball
so I'm about going to that Giants game
and keeping score eating the peanuts
drinking that [ __ ] course I liked it
you know I went down I bought some
cigars the other day right I'll bill you
french fries you smoking cigars you
drinking beer what are you doing McCoy
by self I walked into this cigar shop
and I can be honest I walked in there
you know it's also a lounge where people
could smoke a chip and I have never seen
anybody smoking a cigar who did not look
like they would just totally [ __ ]
relaxed just absolutely absolutely in
heaven
you know like true cigar smokers I walk
in every time I walk in I took a look at
that guy just sitting there cuz I always
have [ __ ] to do so I run in and I buy
him and I run out but I would see people
just sitting there don't think that's
what that's how you do it come down in
the middle of the day honey I'm going
out for me where you going none of your
business
who is she her name is luck
Aurora emerald Aurora emerald all right
that's it everybody I will see you
tomorrow night if you're here in Dublin
if not I'll check it on you on Thursday